[Music]
which is better deep glow or sapphire
glow in this video i'm going to compare
the two and let you know which one comes
out on top
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and welcome to my video
comparing the deep glow and sapphire
glow plugins these are two of my
favorite plugins for after effects and
for getting that perfect glow so i'm
excited to share my thoughts with you
today first up we've got the deep glow
plugin and to apply it we go to effect
plug in everything deep glow and right
out of the box this is what deep glow
looks like next we've got sapphire glow
we'll go to effect
sapphire lighting
s glow
and right out of the box this is what
this plugin looks like out of the box
no adjustments to the settings sapphire
glow has a better glow but we can make
some adjustments to each of these
plugins to get their look
even better so let's do that to deep
glow the first thing we need to look at
is dropping the radius so i'm going to
drop the radius down to something
just around 200 maybe 191 something like
that
and we're also going to drop the
exposure way down to something like
point one we're also going to open up
input and increase the threshold
to something like
40 maybe 41 we're also going to go ahead
and smooth out that threshold to a 100
smoothness now one thing i really like
about the deep globe plug-in is the fact
that it has chromatic aberration built
into the plug-in so i can turn that on
and immediately we get some nice
chromatic aberration for this particular
image i'm going to go ahead and switch
it to
green and blue and increase the amount
to about 0.3 i also really like the fact
that we can go ahead and tent this so
that's with and without let's go ahead
and open up the color and let's pick a
color
somewhere in this range
right here and click ok and after a few
adjustments to this deep globe plugin
we've got a really nice glow going on so
if i take a screenshot and i reset this
to the original this is the original
this is how we adjusted the glow plugin
to get a really nice glow
and also if i go ahead and undo that if
i turn off the effect this is with deep
glow and this is without so we created a
really nice stylized image with deep
glow by adjusting a few settings next
let's jump into sapphire glow
and we're going to go ahead and adjust a
few settings here as well one thing i do
want to mention is that sapphire glow
has some really awesome presets built
right into it which we can click and see
how they look very easily we can also
pick one of these as a starting point
for our glow so maybe something like
neon lights that's looking pretty cool
but let's go ahead and reset that and
let's go back down here to some of our
settings let's go ahead and change our
color to something like pink so this is
something very similar to the tent in
deep glow go ahead and find a nice pink
color
like so and we're going to drop our
threshold down just a little bit
maybe in this area here it's also nice
that sapphire has these adjustments in
here that we can play around with the
different widths
vertically and horizontally to get some
really interesting looks so i can
drag these handles here i can
pull
red green and blue sliders in and out to
get a really stylized look or i can also
come over here
and adjust these settings as well so
maybe drop this down to about 56 percent
drop this down
about 1.4
with y we're going to go ahead and take
it down to about 1.1
with the red we're going to go ahead and
increase this
we'll take the
with green down just a little bit
take the width blue up a little bit
and there we go this is with a few
adjustments and if we go ahead and reset
that
again we can see that we can make some
really nice glows here let's go ahead
and undo that and let's go ahead and
just turn off glow and back on
and we've got a really nice look here so
if you compare the two at this point
there is deep glow there is sapphire
glow
both have really nice looks personally
i'm going to go with sapphire glow i
really enjoy boris effects plugins
over any other plugins out there on the
market and this is going to be my winner
for most of the work that i do i hope
that you really enjoyed this lesson on
deep glow versus sapphire glow please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments below i'd love to answer
them for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it really helps other
people find the channel when you
subscribe if you're looking to upgrade
your design skill set master the
artist's style and execute like a pro i
have a course called stylecraft that you
can check out at motionscience.tv
you can also learn more about this
course by clicking the link in the
description below
as always thanks for watching my name is
cameron and this is motion science
[Music]
you